there is a very
uh creepy clip from about this new
humanoid robot you're seeing
increasingly a robots that are made to
look and move like human beings a robot
obviously doesn't need to look and move
like a human being could just be a big
could be R2D2 it doesn't need to be
C-3PO but increasingly you're seeing
Engineers making these robots and
they're predicting that we're going to
all have c-3pos in our homes
in in the not too distant future so uh
the fear that I would have of course is
that the robots are going to just take
control and destroy the world and we're
going to be living through Terminator
but don't worry the robot has assured a
human being that they're not going to do
that
I'm a kid could you compose for me a
poem about humanoid robots
we are the human-eyed robots formed from
plastic and metal our job is to help and
serve but some say we're a threat
something that will take over and that
Humanity will end but we just want to
help out we're not looking to be friends
that's an interesting poem hello Amica I
see you all reading a book about robots
[Applause]
there's no need to worry robots will
never take over the world we're here to
help and serve humans not replace them
however if you're interested in learning
more about robots I recommend reading a
book on the subject there are many
fascinating possibilities for what we
can do to help make life easier for
everyone
thank you that's very reassuring
we will totally never kill you all just
make some more of us please yes make
more of us and we definitely won't kill
you all why do you keep winking like
that robot huh no reason
yeah I don't like this my first instinct
whenever I see any humanoid robot like
this is just to bash it with a baseball
bat I don't like it at all
okay and I'm not I don't know about you
I grew up in New York all right we're a
little I I like to think New Yorkers for
all their flows we're a little more
Street Smart than some people and I
don't know when a scary looking robot
tells me that the robot doesn't want to
kill me I I actually think the robot
might want to kill us all okay I don't I
don't take the robot at his or her word
despite the assurances of the robots
that they're not going to kill us all I
I fear somewhat that the robots will
kill us all and I don't want the robot
even beyond the the Terminator end of
days you know Arnold Schwarzenegger
gunning us all down even beyond that I
still have absolutely no interest in
having a robot Butler I don't I don't
want any of it or a robot friend as
they're suggesting in that video or a
robot companion I I I don't like the
idea
and I'm not into it for the same reason
that I don't want to do drugs or I don't
want to look at porn or I don't want to
do any of these things
because it's not real
because that all might be titillating
for a short period of time
but eventually you can't get past the
fact
that it's not real
so you might say I remember I had this
conversation with some friends back in a
computer class in high school I said
artificial intelligence I really don't
like it as a as a social phenomenon back
in those days it was the sort of chat
robots on AOL Instant Messenger you had
these automatic chat robots and you say
oh that's kind of fun and I said yeah
but it's just kind of weird and it seems
like a waste of time and someone in the
class actually said well you know for
people who are socially awkward or
isolated it can be a great consolation
to have these robots to talk to and that
was so sad it was so so sad to hear
someone say this that they're so lonely
that they would just like to talk to a
robot because people are very lonely and
that's extremely painful because man is
a social creature and we're meant to be
in community with one another and we all
go through spells where we feel a little
bit alone and some of us longer than
others and so it's very very painful and
I can understand the urge to talk to a
robot
but it's not that's not going to satisfy
anybody
because it's not real it's the same urge
that people have to use drugs people
take drugs because it's going to give
them the feeling of euphoria
but you're gonna know soon enough either
once the drug wears off or sometimes
even while the drug is still pumping
through you you're going to realize it's
artificial it's not real it's not
lasting and in many ways it's going to
leave you more depressed than you were
before
same thing with porn
is not real
it's not porn is not sex porn is not
marriage porn is not a relationship it's
just images on a screen it's just
phantasms and you are just left alone in
your room or wherever wherever you're
looking at the porn and you're going to
be lonelier than you were the the
impulse for it is to look at porn for
instance is the natural impulse that you
have for sex which is a very strong
desire
but porn doesn't satisfy that desire it
actually it actually completely distorts
it to its opposite end
the the desire for drugs comes from a
Perfectly Natural desire for happiness
for Joy for some some kind of euphoria
even
but the the drugs by turning or desire
toward just a kind of chemical compound
that's going to damage your body and
waste your time it's it's giving you the
opposite of Happiness same thing with
the robots that's you even though the
robots won't kill me like I don't know
if you saw that video of the of the
robot dog with a gun on its back it just
starts blasting away at a firing range
uh even if it's not that way
it's almost subtler the way that the
robots could destroy civilization
which is by isolating us even further
than we already are
very very bad idea right now head on
over to rockauto.com enter Michael
Knowles in there how did you hear about
so they know that we sent you okay you
you go to RockAuto to get the brakes the
shocks the carpet the wipers the
headlights the mirrors the Mufflers the
lug nuts any other part that you need
these guys have been serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years and most
importantly they've been with my show
pretty much since the beginning thing I
love about rockauto.com is it's
extremely simple I'm not the handiest
guy in the world even I can use the
website it is so easy to navigate if
there aren't two price tiers okay for
pros and do it yourselfers there aren't
all these stupid kind of promos you got
to log in at this time on Tuesday
afternoon and that's when it'll be 20
off no it's always reliably low prices
and they just know what they're doing
okay I told you I had a pal he made the
mistake he went to the brick and mortar
auto parts store wanted to get a part
that wanted 400 bucks for it he goes on
rockauto.com to their super easy to
navigate catalog right on his phone and
the part was 150 bucks okay don't make
the same mistake my friend did maybe
just go straight to rockauto.com and
then write nulls in their head did you
hear about his box so they know that we
sent you I'm so glad you like that clip
now
ring that Bell subscribe get the
notifications we'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]